Speaker 1: It is still really unclear to me, but
also to Nikki Haley, why anyone should vote for
her. According to Nikki Haley, we talked last
week about how Nikki Haley was asked, like,
why? Why would people vote for you? And it
was basically like, I don't really know. And
identity politics. Well, I'm a I'm a different
generation. And, you know, women power and I'm
also a minority. And just very strange stuff to
hear from Republicans who claim to be against
identity politics. She's now had another week to
try to come up with some policy ideas. She was
asked about her record at the U.N. She could
name nothing other than that she did a book.
She didn't write a book. She did a book. Are
these do these count as answers in politics
at this point? Are in Republican politics.
Speaker 5: We've been talking about foreign
policy this morning. You did an incredible job at
the U.N. Good thing for America.
First, how will you differentiate
yourself from the other candidates and.
Speaker 1: From the other candidates?
TRUMP Right. I mean, that's it's Trump
and Vivek Ramaswamy who who's whose
announcement went over like a lead balloon.
Speaker 5: Your plan for foreign policy.
Speaker 1: Give us the plan.
Speaker 6: Well, you know,
one of the main things I did at the United
Nations that I think is so important is I did
a book that focused on the 193 company countries.
Speaker 1: That are 93 companies. And oh, my God,
let's we've got to run that back to the
this this is an answer. She was asked,
what would you do in terms of foreign policy?
Speaker 6: Well, you know, one of the main
things I did at the United Nations that
I think is so important is I did a book
that focused on the 193 company countries, the
percentage of time they voted with us
and how much foreign aid we give them.
Speaker 1: Yeah, chef. Can you tell us what
would be your approach to poultry based dishes
if you were to be hired to run this restaurant?
Listen, one of the biggest things I did over the
last three months is I did a book. Where I would
list items available at different restaurants.
Oh. Oh, okay. But so what would what would the
poultry dishes be here? It's just completely
incoherent. And by the way, she did a book
containing information. Anyone can just
Google about different countries. And by the
way, it's not even clear she actually claims
to have written it. Notice that she said she
did a book rather than I wrote a book. This is
really a problem in my eyes. I don't know that
the Republican voters care about policy, but
she continues to do this. Remember last week she
was asked, you know what, like why would anyone
vote for you? And just very confusing answers.
Speaker 7: Okay. So I want to put up something
for The Wall Street Journal this week. They said
you had a great day, your great rollout day,
but they said you have to provide a rationale
for your candidacy that you haven't done yet.
They said you've got to answer this question
about why you versus anybody else in the in
the GOP field. You know, they're talking about
the fact that you say, you know, America first,
America should be powerful. Those are things that
any GOP candidate is going to say. So why you?
Speaker 6: Why not me? You know, I am a the wife
of a combat veteran. I'm a mother of two children,
one who's getting married. And I see how
hard it is for her to look at buying a home,
one that's in college. And I see what he's
dealing with with work, education. You know,
I'm the daughter of immigrant parents who are
upset by what's happening at the border. I
don't want to wait for someone else to fix this.
Speaker 1: Anyway, so her, as you might remember,
her answer was basically, you know, there's
there's people not enjoying what they're
being taught and woke. And, you know, I'm I'm
the daughter of immigrants. Truly a horrendous
candidate. I mean, just horrifyingly bad. And
usually candidates are able to cite reasons to
vote for them, which we might say that's not a
good reason. She's not even able to cite what
would count as a reason. Now, if we want to
take a very quick look at the latest polling.
You know, it's not as bad as I thought for Nikki
Haley. If we look at the most recent A-rated poll,
which is a Fox News poll, remember,
Fox News polling actually isn't bad.
It's conducted by Beacon Research. They have
a poll. If it's Trump, head to head against
Haley. Trump crushes Haley 66 to 24. And that's
not super shocking. If it's a multi-way poll,
it's Trump 43, followed by DeSantis 28, and
then Nikki Haley tied for third with 7%,
7%. Nothing to sneeze at given that she just
launched her campaign a couple of weeks ago.
It's not great. And by the way, if I was a
betting man, I'm not. My bet is Nikki Haley
does not end up getting 7% of the vote in the
Republican primary. But it's not even March of
2023 yet. So. So, you know, who knows? But
listen, I mean, she's starting with seven,
all right? That's something you can build from,
at least hypothetically. I don't know that you're
going to build it by having no policy and just
saying you're younger than Trump, a woman and
and of Indian heritage. I'm not sure that that
gets you beyond 7%, but it will be interesting to
watch. We'll take a very quick break. I am going
to talk about the Scott Adams racist meltdown. I
have a history with Scott Adams. We'll talk about
that and other things after this very short break.